Je suis très excité d'être ici et ça
va être très amusant aujourd'hui et de
rassembler à nouveau des gens
du monde entier pour un seul homme
car c'est très stimulant, c'est très
émouvant de voir tout le monde, tout le monde qui est
si passionné  pour marcher et frapper des
gens de tous âges de toutes générations, ce
sont souvent ceux qui
sont en première ligne, nous devons donc
pouvoir entendre leurs voix, c'est pourquoi
je pense qu'il est si important que
les peuples autochtones quittent ce combat  nous
devrions considérer comme un compliment que nous
avons tellement d'impacts que le fait que les gens
veuillent nous faire taire deviendra trop fort
pour que les gens puissent les gérer, alors ils essaient de
nous faire taire